the 2020 Democratic field is now leaning
even further left without spoken trouble
critic congressman Eric swallow well
jumping into the race basically every
Democrat trying to take on Trump is
pushing radical socialist policies while
at the same time attacking capitalism
the only way to meet some of these
historic challenges is to be able to use
this engine of capitalism now having
said that it is clearly an imperfect
unfair unjust and racist capitalist
economy we are going to transform this
economy and this government and create a
system that works for all of us not just
the 1% I believe in capitalism I see the
wealth that can be produced but let's be
really clear capitalism without rules is
theft
former Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz is
calling out these 2020 liberal
contenders all these politicians who are
crying about capitalism have they ever
made a payroll have they ever worked in
a business what have they done other
than criticize the system we do have a
small crisis of capitalism and what what
I mean by that is that the rules of
engagement for a company today given the
fact that the government can't solve all
these problems is businesses and
business leaders must do more for their
employees and the communities they serve
and we're just learning that Bernie
Sanders says he's gonna release his tax
returns by Monday he's of course
downplaying the fact that he is a
millionaire mr. Gutfeld Bernie's a
millionaire yeah you know and who would
have thought but you know what I'm glad
he's a millionaire I'm glad because
everybody should do the best that they
can the platform that you run on should
be about making a great system greater
not destroying the greatest system
that's ever been created they talk about
inequality capitalism has done more
about inequality than anything if you
look in history everything has been
unequal at least capitalism gives you
the opportunity to move from static
income brackets I've moved in every
income bracket from nothing to
and back again and almost all
inequalities can be explained not by
race but by age the median age for the
japanese-americans is decades higher
than Hispanics so they would have a
higher income than Hispanics because
they're twenty years on average older
once you start looking at these
inequality these these in quality
arguments they kind of fall apart so you
should be embracing capitalism in free
markets because that makes the world a
better place stop complaining
yeah babies it is interesting to see is
someone like Howard Schultz a
full-fledged capitalist and running in
the Democratic Party and Lodging he's
very frustrated right now so he is the
largest job generator of his generation
and remember when he came into the first
interview at Fox
he said that Liz Warren had come to him
asking for a donation and that he had
denied her I also I know exactly I can
tell you exactly when Bernie Sanders is
going to release his tax returns
I know exactly when the bar report comes
out send out the tax returns and no one
that's why you were a press secretary
you definitely understand the timing
Dagan what do you think capitalism under
attack in the primary well if you go
through everything that these major
candidates have talked about it's like a
hunka-hunka burnin socialist pageant
right that there Lizabeth Warren loves
wealth because she most confiscated
that's her plan it is a full on Soviet
Union wealth compensation Union yeah
it's totally communist we're gonna come
and take your money Bernie Sanders get
rid of private insurance he's gonna have
a I guess an addendum to this plan but
he's essentially telling the American
people we're gonna kick 150 to 180
million people off their private
insurance and then Bernie and Liz and
Carla and Cory Booker get to decide what
kind of health care you got and then
Eric's wall well kind of went down the
list the rut you know he's the the Ken
doll of the bunch trying to figure out
which socialist policy hadn't been
claimed yet and now he's going for gun
confiscation so good luck with that we
do have a constitution and a second
amendment we've already forgotten about
bado
that guy faded faster than don't fans
will still kill you there okay one you
know all the Democrats had to do running
again just be normal and not go crazy
and they can't help themselves they are
going crazy I don't think they're going
crazy at all most Americans think we
have income inequality but I wanna be a
saintly start with Howard Schultz okay
Howard Schultz goodness gracious
he is so irrelevant to this whole
conversation except when it serves your
purpose because guess what he's not even
running as a Democrat he's not you
thought independent yeah that's what he
says right now and guess what you know
Howard Schultz the only purpose he
serves right now is to get Trump
reelected do you know to try to divide
up support for demerant gonna run and if
the he will only run of the Democrats
elect somebody so far left in other
words right so he's like you know
kryptonite for Democrat it but anyway
the second point is about capitalism and
I think capitalism is very American I'm
a capitalist but I also think their
rules and rules are very American like I
believe order survival yeah like a
Securities and Exchange Commission do
you guys believe in that do you believe
right so we have a Securities Exchange
Commission that puts limits on
capitalist behavior like we have a
Federal Reserve that handles interest
rates again
them is like a hundred years no but you
remember this is these are all limits
consumer protections Elizabeth Warren
she's gotten a lot of attention with
that that's not a hundred years ago well
that's the point we do not have
unfettered capitalism you guys want to
sit here and celebrate their limits and
we believe in rules and limit they
wanted twenty Hardy taxes not they don't
want to destroy capitalism they want
capitalism that serves the taking away
every American's private health
insurance is not a loan get out of here
yeah Social Security Oh suddenly that's
that's socialist no one's getting our
money here can I quickly say this Bernie
Sanders political director who spent
part of her childhood in Venezuela once
told the Atlantic few years ago it is it
was better to live on poverty level
wages in a shantytown in Venezuela
than on a garment workers salary in
Elizabeth New Jersey this is one of the
many many socialist working on his team
yet the millionaire's campaign Bernie
Sanders Congrats